your favorite YouTuber is killing pop
culture whether it's me Mr Beast the
game grumps binging with babish we are
all guilty in fact all of YouTube's
guilty and it's not just on this
platform either Netflix Disney plus yeah
them too Max Prime video absolutely when
it comes right down to it OnDemand
viewing of entertainment has slowly
eroded away the very fabric of our
Collective cultural identity and whether
you realize it or not that's a key
reason why many of you watching right
now are suffering from depression that's
why anxiety levels are on the rise it's
why America is a political hotbed and
why so many people are questioning how
they fit into the world right now it's
all because of this behind me are the
most expensive cars in the world my
ability to stream Mr Beast right now or
the office today smoking is going to
save lives or
Avengers or Bewitched ketchup with my
oatmeal or friends or breaking bag or
Game of Thrones or Game Theory or film
Theory
hello Internet welcome to film Theory
where we're part of the problem so have
you guys seen Mr BEAST's latest video at
this point that's kind of a legitimate
question because despite being the
number one channel and all of his videos
raking in hundreds of millions of views
there's a nonzero chance that no you
haven't seen it how about Ryan Tran AR
Mr who's the boss these guys are
consistently some of the most watched
creators on the platform right now drawn
in millions of views with each upload
are they showing up on your homepage for
a big chunk of you I guess the answer is
no and I know this because I do actively
watch their stuff and they're not
showing up for me for some reason their
videos just aren't ones that YouTube's
algorithms are recommending to me but
you've noticed this right YouTube is
different this year recommendations feel
different older videos are cropping up
there's more shorts everywhere smaller
creators are getting more visibility and
the things that you're being recommended
are more tied to what you've searched
for or watched recently I mean I watch
the hot ones inter interview with
musician Dave Gro and YouTube thinks I'm
obsessed with drumming I'm getting
recommended drummer covers and drummer
reviews and drummer L did you even know
that there was drummer lore cuz let me
tell you there is basically what's going
on here is that this year has seen some
massive changes on the platform which
merits a whole separate conversation
unto itself but the long and short of it
is that my YouTube doesn't look like
your YouTube anymore you know what
really prove this one to me skibby
toilet seriously true story I was
recently talking to a big room of
Google's higher-ups and I asked them if
they'd ever seen a skibbidy toilet video
you know that insanely popular series of
viral shorts that's gotten over 35
million subscribers and 12 billion views
on their platform in the last 5 months
alone not a single person in the room
had ever heard of it regardless of
whether you think skibby is pure gold or
should be flushed down the toilet it
came from that right there that is
telling and it's not just here on
YouTube either Tik Tok is really the one
that started this whole Trend that's why
you always hear people asking hey what's
on your Tik Tok because in a world where
algorith RMS are selecting what content
you see there's no guarantee that when I
play this that's suspicious you know
what I'm referring to the good of this
is that you're likely getting served
content that's precisely targeted at
your unique viewing habits the bad is
that fewer people are now watching the
same things and believe it or not but
watching the same things is a critical
part of human survival in short if
you've been feeling lonely or anxious or
depressed or potentially all three it's
because the world has become
increasingly fragmented an on demand
streaming entertainment is a perfect
representative of why you're feeling
that way so let's talk about that and
also some ways that we can solve it
first let's just get a sense of the
scale that we're talking about here
think of the biggest shows on television
over the last decade two that stick out
to me are breaking bad and Game of
Thrones absolute Darlings of the
internet there is no doubt that these
were massive deals breaking bats finale
reached 10.3 million people when it
originally aired meanwhile Game of
Thrones captured 13.6 million with
another 5.7 million watching a rerun or
streaming VOD Within 24 hours those are
incredible numbers for a modern show and
yet they're nothing compared to what TV
shows saw pre- streaming for example
let's take a look at Star Trek the Next
Generation when this show finished in
1994 how many people do you think
watched the series finale more than 31
million a show that at the time was
considered by many to be Niche nerd
content actually tapped into nearly
three times the viewers of a modern
program and the numbers just get more
insane as you look across more popular
IP 52.5 million people watched Friends
as it ended Seinfeld got a whopping 76.3
million viewers I kid you not people
were literally gathered at Times Square
to watch the finale together cheers was
sent off with 80.4 million viewers and
mash ended with nearly 106 million
people making it the single most watched
broadcast in American history that
wasn't a Super Bowl a president
resigning or a moon landing sure Mr
Beast can pull 100 million viewers no
sweat but that's talking Global numbers
across the span of a couple days with
ads that are randomly decided by an
algorithm based on your tastes and
randomly Place throughout the video
based on how you tend to watch videos by
contrast these massive TV moments where
people all at the same time all in the
US all watching an event unfold together
in real time it was scheduled into their
lives streets were empty everyone was
fed the same commercials at the exact
same time and when it ended everyone was
released as one big unit so afterwards
when I said the tribe has spoken or what
up or eat my shorts you got it you knew
the references I was citing and you were
able to respond back in C it was a
shared cultural lingo that you could
reasonably assume most people you talk
to had also been exposed to but think
about what that means in the age of on
demand video in the age of YouTube of
Tik Tok and Netflix what can you rely on
people to actually know that's just a
theory yeah maybe but for as big as our
channels are we've always been Niche
like comment and subscribe sure but it's
also too broad it's too vague that's on
everything from a beauty Vlog to a
locksmithing how too says nothing about
who you are who we are as consumers of
content and of course this isn't only
affect ing TV Avengers endgame was the
last big cultural movie moment to happen
in theaters and now just four or 5 years
later the pop culture encyclopedia has
largely run dry IP like Marvel and Star
Wars were among the last holdouts of
shared cultural touchstones but because
of how they've been strip mind for
Content their importance and relevance
have largely been on the downswing with
ever decreasing box office returns and
what's risen up to replace them nothing
well nothing except the Taylor Swift
eras tour streaming in theaters but
again why is that such a big cultural
Touchstone well because she's one of the
only artists to have made it big before
this on demand explosion with albums
droing in 2006 2008 2010 and 2012 All
Before Spotify came in and solidified
music as the ond demand entertainment
Source it is today and as a result of
getting a foothold early she's been able
to maintain relevance through consistent
releases ever since leading us to today
where she's one of the few music acts
that have been able to achieve such huge
critical mass and cross generational
boundaries but after Tay Tay who's next
who Rises up what musical acts have had
the same sort of cultural relevance
internationally I'd say K-pop comes
pretty close but the audience is now too
divided for any one artist to attain
that much of your attention and so I
can't just turn to the person next to me
and ask if they stand Kim ta young or
make a casual reference to color
changing soup and just expect them to
know what I'm talking about now on one
hand this rise of on demand viewing is a
good thing theoretically you're being
shown things that actually interest you
videos movies games and music that are
all tailored to your specific individual
wants and needs instead of what a
corporate Board of DOR s in Burbank
California deemed to be the next popular
thing but because we don't know what
anyone else has seen is listening to is
playing quoting or meming we lose the
pop in pop culture at the end of the day
you don't have popular culture if
nothing is actually popular with
everyone but why is that matter can't we
all just live in our happy little
Bubbles and carry on well it turns out
that at the end of the day that bubble
doesn't end up being very happy the
reason is that popular culture supplies
us with a lot more than hummable tunes
and weird Euphoria Clips where
everyone's crying IT Supplies us with
connection one of the easiest ways to
connect with someone that you don't know
is to find a piece of Ip that you both
know something about wait a minute you
also watched the finale of Seinfeld well
hello oh you saw Infinity War why didn't
they just go for the head you listen to
Taylor Swift 2o that's awesome what a is
your favorite but as Pop Culture becomes
more individualized the group we feel
that we can truly connect with becomes
smaller and smaller does that sound like
I'm overstating the importance of these
connections well it turns out the
fracturing of Pop Culture platforms
coincides with a huge rise in feelings
of loneliness and isolation in our
society especially here in the US where
we've already placed a high value on the
idea of Independence a Gallup poll from
1980 showed that 20% of the population
felt lonely that same poll in 2020
reported that 36% of people more than
one in three was grappling with some
form of serious loneliness but that was
2020 right that was the pandemic you
think that coming back from the pandemic
would have improved the situation but
polls in 2023 2 years after lockdowns
have ended in most places they show that
loneliness continues to climb with some
studies reporting 60% of respondents
feeling isolated lonely or struggling to
make personal connections and these
stats aren't just like oh that's really
sad it's an epidemic that
disproportionately affects people under
the age of 25 that's not to say older
Generations haven't dealt with mental
health or loneliness they do frequently
but it often goes under diagnosed in
those populations that said the
statistics overwhelmingly show that the
vast majority of younger people are
dealing with loneliness on a regular
basis and they're of course also the
people that have spent their lives in
this fractured pop cultural world with
fewer anchor points that connect them to
other people instead the only things
that unite us now the only things that
are truly able to cut through the noise
are the tragedies in an absence of fun
moments like a new Star Wars movie or an
Avengers film or a new concert bad news
is the thing that rises to the top of
every social media feed natural
disasters shootings War political
upheaval and while it isn't bad that
people are more aware of those problems
and in justices this constant cycle of
never-ending bad news with absolutely no
levity cutting through has had a marked
effect on the mental health of younger
Generations but okay I hear you saying
that it's not fair to blame all our
loneliness and isolation on these
platforms like the fact that my Tik Tok
doesn't serve me the same goalie cat
clip yours does makes the world a sadder
place now of course not it's not only
the platforms but pop culture is part of
a much bigger splintering that only
looks worse the more you dig in Pub
culture obviously isn't the only way we
relate to other people there are lots
ways that people share interests and
feel like we live in a society and these
ways are often listed out in various
identity theories that have been made
across history Sports religion your job
your ethnic background maybe your
political views any of these things
might be enough to bring you together
with someone else the problem is that
we're losing ground in these areas as
well all of them for instance looking at
religious service attendance it peaked
in 1960 and it's been on the decline for
the last 30 years in fact it dropped 10%
since 2012 alone what about our shared
love of the good old us OFA patriotism
in the US has also plummeted across the
last 10 years most significantly among
younger people on top of being the prime
demographic to feel lonely and isolated
young people on platforms like YouTube
and Tik Tok are also more likely to be
politically informed and they've become
cynical about their political identity
in 2016 almost 40% of people under 29
reported feeling proud to be an American
and then they hum that lyric by Lee
Greenwood checking back in 2023 that
number is just 18% so okay not really
connecting on religion or patriotism but
hey you can always meet people at your
job never mind the workplace has been
completely upended in the Last 5 Years
just in time for Gen Z to enter the
workforce and look for jobs but maybe
those jobs are remote jobs maybe they're
in person maybe it's havies maybe it's
the gig economy maybe they'll strike and
all the while there'll be a ton of
inflation and Logan Paul is going to be
telling them they should be investing in
crypto 70% of Millennials and jenzy
workers are considering quitting their
jobs as I speak and high percentages of
Gen X workers in fields like Tech and
Healthcare are feeling burned out due to
work and finances people's identities
are no longer associated with the place
they work because people don't view
those places as reliable or helpful
anymore they feel financially insecure
and underpaid enough so that basically
half of all Zoomers Millennials and gen
xers all have themselves a side hustle
my parents by contrast have worked in
the same job for over 40 years so for
them their job is a core part of their
identity but for young people now
they're disillusioned with corporate
culture and mostly just want to get out
so your job's not making you any
positive connections these days what
then does that leave us with well
according to Identity Theory it leaves
us with things like extreme political
views or extreme viewpoints on topics
like gender or extreme stances on race
all these areas where we've historically
worked to break down barriers improve
communication and at least attempt to
work together instead walls are now
getting built back up as we attempt to
Define ourselves by how we're different
from the other side the scope of all of
of those things goes well beyond this
little old theory on the internet but
suffice it to say these are areas where
a large percent of the population also
feels divided or isolated or scared and
doesn't feel able to connect with those
on the other side of the issue so the
tldr is that if you feel like it's a
really lonely time out there and it's
bizarrely hard to make connections with
your fellow humans on any basic level
you're right we are more fractured and
divided than ever everywhere we turn and
it's because the institutions around us
that used to give us connection and
identity are crumbling so what then do
we do in a time when we really want to
feel connected with something what's the
thing that'll help make us feel
connected how do you possibly beat a
series of systems that keep us siloed
well ironically it's in the place where
we started this episode stories whether
that's in YouTube videos movies TV video
games wherever hearing other people's
genuine stories about what they're going
through makes us feel connected to them
it helps us understand that other people
are going through what we're going
through it helps us to feel like we're
not alone they help us feel seen one of
the most popular movies of the last year
has been Puss and Boots The Last Wish
hugely inexplicably popular except
what's it about well the theme is
identity it's about being lonely it's
about finding your place and your
relationship with someone else when the
identity you thought you had crumbles
away huh go figure kind of matches what
we're talking about or how about the
biggest movie of the year Barbie you
know the story about a person Dow thing
in a world where their role used to be
clear-cut but now she doesn't know what
her place is anymore what her identity
is which has left her feeling say with
me now lonely and isolated and she finds
herself in the end by being a woman and
there's that big speech in there about
how hard it is to be a mother and a
woman and how there's so many
expectations oh my gosh it's almost like
this whole movie is relatable the
stories that now cut through the noise
don't shy away from this splintered
feeling instead they face those feelings
headon authenticity and honesty about
the one universal that we all feel
loneliness is actually what's helping to
unite us YouTube which has been the
world's most frantic viewing experience
for for the last 3 years is just now
fully finding itself swinging in the
opposite direction simple conversations
with moist critical about current events
human experiences like eating with Eddie
burbach and Ted nion at margaritaville's
the lonely man's Cuisine investing in
human stories is feeling refreshing
again even Mr Beast has openly talked
about pulling back from his ADHD
inducing editing style to a narrative
format where he sounds more human and
allows an actual story to unfold in his
videos because that's what's keeping
people engaged rather than just more and
more suitcase of money opening up every
10 seconds will this instantly solve all
our problems the root cause that makes
us feel so divided have us feeling great
and making lots of friends and have
hairbraiding sleepover soon no
definitely not but there's a recognition
out there that talking to real people
telling real stories and being honest
about where we are it pays off while
we're in this phase of splintered
existence seek out the real Great
stories that feel honest to where you
are right now don't be afraid to talk
about what it's like to be lonely and do
it in increments that are longer than 3
seconds you can could even go out on a
limb and not set it to a trending sound
it's not guaranteed that everyone else
you know will see the same things you
will watch the same movies you will play
the same games or have the same
experiences but the important thing is
that by watching and sharing stories
that are real and relatable we'll start
a new pop cultural Trend built on what
it means to be human with all the ups
and downs that that entails you know
what it's not a bad place to start but
hey that's just a theory a film Theory
and
cut
[Music]